[موسيقى]
درجات الحرارة المرتفعة ، والتربة الرملية
ومصادر المياه منخفضة الجودة
، كل هذا يجعل الصحراء مكانًا صعبًا
للغاية لزراعة
الغذاء إلا إذا كنت من نبات الساليكورنيا مثل
هذه التي تكافح الظروف القاسية
وتعطينا طعمًا للزراعة
سيبدو الساليكورنا في المستقبل
كبطل صحراوي خارق
من حيث الملوحة التي يمكنه تحملها
والبقاء على قيد الحياة في ظل هذا النوع من الظروف القاسية التي
تتحدى أنواع الطعام التي يمكن أن
تنمو في الصحراء هي اللحوم
والبطاطس من المركز الدولي
للملوحة الحيوية  الزراعة في دبي
هنا في رحلة بحث عالمية عن
محاصيل مغذية مقاومة للحرارة يمكن أن
تنمو في أقسى الظروف
باستخدام موارد المياه المالحة
والتربة الرملية ، يمكننا زراعة
المحاصيل بطريقة غير تقليدية
لتعزيز إنتاج الغذاء على المستوى المحلي.
بالنسبة لهذا العمل
، تشكل الأحداث المناخية الشديدة ومحدودية مصادر المياه العذبة
تهديدًا حقيقيًا
للإمدادات الغذائية العالمية
، حيث يفتخر المركز بمجموعة فريدة من
المزيد  في 13 ألف بذرة من جميع
أنحاء العالم في حالة الكينوا ،
اختبر الفريق ألف ومائتي
اختلاف ووجد خمسة أنواع يمكن أن تنمو
في الصحراء
من البحث إلى الممارسة.
خطط كبيرة
لساليكورنيا
نحن نتطلع إلى تطوير بسكويت
برجر بسكويت من الساليكورنيا للمنتجات الغذائية على
أمل
أن يتم طرح هذه المنتجات في السوق
قريبًا جدًا
اليوم 41 مليون شخص
على حافة المجاعة
مع تحول الأراضي الزراعية إلى صحاري
تعد تقنيات الزراعة الجديدة
خيارًا حقيقيًا لإطعام البلدان الجائعة
وستتخذ الشركات خيارات حول
كيفية رغبتها في دمج
أنظمة النمو المختلفة ، وسيكون لدينا
دور تقريبًا لكل نوع مختلف من
أنظمة
المحاصيل وكل تقنية زراعة مختلفة في
أجزاء مختلفة  من العالم
حيث يعمل تغير المناخ على تكثيف
تقنيات الزراعة الذكية مثل برنامج icba الذي يثبت
ذلك لتحقيقه  التكيف مع الأمن الغذائي
هو السبيل الوحيد للمضي قدمًا نينا دوس سانتوس سي إن إن